Hôm nay là lần đầu 1 trả nhiệm đi mê chô đây, và sĩn sò như thế, đúng chủ miệng bỏ nguồn.
Mại bật bị nè nè dờ đi mê chô không thường tình mặt nguồn.
Chị cây chẳng hẹt tự ký là đi được ngay.
Sơn, hóa dàng quá tỉnh, vẫn tất tìm đi chô này.
Chị em, tháng mấy cái khóa phà miếng phối nữa đó.
Không lắng kẹt xe, không khói lối chỉ cần gọi chiến chiến tự hổn hồi.
Cầm dếp, đàn của một thành phí lớn nào đó trên thế giới gầy.
Hôm nay là thành phố của tuần nình, và mừng trế yêu từng cũng này hướng bây giờ hết.
Lời đầy không chỉ đẹp, mời còn ngay kẹn dài.
Mày chô không chỉ giúp từ mình đi lại nhìn chấm, mời còn mấy đếm dếp, kẹp thật thời ngái.
Trong một cái đi dài, tôi làm người tởi hè, khi là một không có thành phố này.